[Music]
hi Evan here I'm a technical curriculum
developer for Google Cloud and I'm
Sandra I work on our cloud sales team on
this episode we'll introduce you to
Cloud Data lab an interactive tool for
exploring analyzing and visualizing
large scale data sets with just a few
clicks we'll also take you through a
quick demo of a self-paced lab we'll
create a data Lab instance as well as
create and manage a new notebook cloud
data lab aims to help you get valuable
insights from raw data while exploring
publishing and sharing reports in a fast
and cost-effective way Digga lab is
targeted largely at data scientists
creating jupiter' notebooks previously
ipython has been a very popular way for
data scientists to analyze data so it's
no coincidence that data lab is based on
Jupiter and is also open source and what
this gives you is access to a large set
of open source Python libraries for data
analysis visualization and machine
learning scenarios that your fellow data
scientists have already written what it
means for you is that the notebooks
written by your peers can easily be
brought into data lab which runs on
Google clouds infrastructure as Evan
mentioned the real power of data lab
comes from its integration with other
Google cloud platform services data lab
runs on Google compute engine so you can
choose a machine type with the
performance and cost characteristics
that suits your data analysis needs in
terms of scalability analyzing terabytes
or petabytes of data is no problem at
all because of the easy connections to
other Google cloud big data services
all right it's time for the quick labs
and this hands-on lab which takes about
30 minutes to complete and I'll show you
how to create a data lab instance and
create a new notebook we'll also show
you how to use uncut in your browser and
get from the command line to manage your
notebooks you can check out the link to
start the quick lab here at this point
in the lab we've created a cloud data
lab instance called my data lab
we've used the web preview to access the
data lab homepage
we then created a new notebook
ran the code and saved the notebook here
we're opening the notebooks repository
using onion we give the commit a title
and commit the new notebook to the cloud
data lab VM repo and push to the master
branch to see the commit we made using
the command-line we SSH into the data
lab VM and open up an interactive shell
session inside of the cloud data lab
container
we can navigate to the notebooks
directory in the container and see the
git log and this will include the commit
of our brand-new notebook
well that brings us to the end of
another episode and we hope you enjoyed
it if you'd like to learn more about
cloud data lamp or other GCP products
you can check out our training resources
below if you haven't done so already
check out this link where you can apply
what you've learned using a three
hundred dollar free trial credit on
Google cloud platform
thanks again for watching and we'll see
you again soon